ukraine's political crisis which way now
in the interview former president of the
european parliament pat cox mr. Cox has
the European Union lost Ukraine that's a
very dramatic way to put the question
when you're dealing with a complex
process I think the idea that there's
some finite endpoint is too dramatic
there's no doubt that what did not
happen in Vilnius was a disappointment
which was a summit with the eastern a
summer of Eastern Partnership Ukraine
decided one week before at a meeting of
the cabinet of ministers of the
government to suspend the signature this
was dramatic this was disappointing
President Yanukovych told at the summit
meeting which I had the privilege to
attend and two here at firsthand that
his strategy to connect Ukraine to
Europe remains unchanged and without
being naive but taking the good fate of
what people tell you into account I
would say it's too dramatic to say
failure and end I would say in the
grammar of the moment it is a comma but
not necessarily a full stop but it looks
like Russia has won a tug-of-war do you
agree I think the real question to do it
you know this tug is Ukraine is an
independent and sovereign state and it
is important especially under the
Helsinki Accords that we respect the
independence and sovereignty of states
my feeling was looking at the nature of
the target is Russian commercial
pressure in addition to other pressures
that from that perspective they accept
that Ukraine is independent and
sovereign put in some parts of its
sovereignty that it is on free to
exercise that sovereignty Russia Ukraine
and the you you will come back later to
this you are serving
as a special envoy of the European
Parliament together with former polish
president Alexander Nevsky what is the
exact goal of your mission to Ukraine we
were privileged interlocutors between
the European Union in general and
Ukraine on three specific sets of issues
the first and primary issue was under
question of selective justice former
ministers including but not only a mrs
tymoshenko who were in prison there was
a strong humanitarian dimension to do it
health particularly for mrs tymoshenko
also for mr. lutsenko the former
interior minister and also mr. eva
shiancoe the former acting defense
minister we dis then spread if I might
say to a wider connection and
conversation on reform questions
electoral reform judicial reform
prosecution service reform where did
these reforms come from these were the
conditions set by the Foreign Affairs
Council of the ministers of the member
states of the European Union and we were
invited to encourage Ukrainian
government and opposition forces who
frankly don't trust each other and don't
work with each other in raghav Narada at
least on the European agenda to find the
serenity and the wisdom to work together
and I think in that the mission made
considerable progress the you had made
mrs tymoshenko is released to to secure
her release for medical treatment abroad
in germany presumably as a precondition
to sign the treaty in vernius but in the
dramatic days you just mentioned these
talks between the Ukrainian leadership
and Russia and these dramatic days the
you dropped this package deal do you
think this was the right decision I
think I think the best way to interpret
and understand this is that the foreign
ministers in December 2012 said three
conditions they were electoral reform
judicial prosecution reform and dealing
with quite sick questions of selective
justice
the foreign ministers if you read their
conclusions carefully never closed the
door on Ukraine they had set the
conditions they never said precisely
whether the conditions are absolute and
how they will review them at the end
they were due to consult each other in
the week of the Vilnius summit but by
that time having kept the door open we
discovered that Ukraine had at least
temporarily decided to close the door
yes but at the same time mrs. Tymoshenko
has become such a symbol figure and now
her faith looks somewhat second grade
well this is one of the reasons why
President crows nests Kyo myself among
many reasons are willing in principle to
resume a mission it's in a different
circumstance but only in the conditions
that such a mission would be acceptable
to all sides governmental and our
position in Ukraine as regards mrs
tymoshenko I think it is extremely
important to understand that vigilance
matters there is a duty of care on the
European institutions and on member
states to remain vigilant in her case
and that vigilance should have a strong
humanitarian focus because as we know
from the diagnosis of the doctors of the
charity clinic in Berlin she needs
operations I'm sure in principle and in
practice such operations could take
place in Ukraine but the truth is
unhappily and for reasons that you know
are not may be entirely fanciful mrs
tymoshenko does not want to have any
invasive medical process inside Ukraine
she doesn't trust the system many
analysts say the EU was completely
unprepared for that geopolitical power
game the Russians President Putin then
started do your share this view I think
the very I think that's a very good
question and I think it's a question the
European Union will need to reflect on
carefully I think this whole
neighborhood is a neighborhood that
clays on the Russian side by different
rules so I think what we've got to do is
to be engaged
as we have been but not to be naive
Russia like other states in principle
should respect the independence and
sovereignty of Ukraine but in practice
when the sovereign Ukraine appeared to
indicate a preference to sign a European
agreement Russia has not been able to
accept that and made interventions
economically that were critical and I
think when we see people now in the
street on the other side Europe has to
understand that this manifestation we
see of popular opinion it shows
something of a a qualitative difference
to what is happening in Ukraine today
it's not the politics of 2004 it's the
people of 2013 giving a strong people's
expression and opinion polls have shown
this weather even in eastern Ukraine let
alone Western Ukraine which
traditionally was more western-oriented
young Ukraine clearly wishes to connect
to the idea the ideal to the
transformative capacity of a European
engagement and that's what we're now
seeing in the streets Russian officials
have want the West want the you want you
do not interfere in Ukrainian internal
affairs what do you respond I would say
I agree one hundred percent with that
but I don't I don't frankly I don't buy
any Russian propaganda let me explain
the mission we had was a mission of
assistance not of interference admission
by invitation not by self appointment
admission whose mandate was renewed on
four occasions with the express approval
of the government of Ukraine of the
opposition of Ukraine and of the leaders
of every political group in the European
Parliament and only in those conditions
or question I skin myself prepared to
work in a system where we were invited
to assist but not to interfere I saw
terms being used by Russians you know
but the watchdog kind of term about
kwasniewski and myself you know people
are entitled to use revell
propagandistic images they want but I
want to tell you this
we neither barked nor bit unlike some
Russians who bid quite a lot in the last
few months reflecting upon future
relations between the EU and Russia is
Russia a partner or arrival by strong
view all along and it remains my view is
that a zero-sum politics European Union
to Russia makes no sense meaning one
side wins one side loses this is the
formula typically wear some time
everyone loses and so the indispensable
quality of an EU Russian engagement is a
win-win potential for both sides that
said in the Eastern Partnership policy
which is now there for five years there
should be some principles which are
already in principle signed up to buy
everyone that should be respected one is
the integrity of the borders of states
and two is the integrity of the
sovereignty of the principle of
sovereignty of states and frankly in
this case the sovereignty of an
independent Ukraine to be able to
exercise an independent sovereign
judgment was interfered with by a third
party mr. Cox let's look ahead what to
do in the weeks to come what should the
you do in Ukraine now what will you be
doing I think for the European Union and
right now we have to give a very clear
message Ukraine is is in a very fragile
place to the authorities the message
please respect the right of free
assembly and the right of free
expression and please do not unleash
security forces against unarmed
civilians going about their ordinary
democratic rights and expression to the
people in Maidan and up and down the
country in Ukraine please be there
express what you want but do not engage
in acts of provocation or violence
Europe has said it keeps the door open
that is good but that is passive we must
not
simply abandoned Ukraine to where phase
will bring it the part of history is not
paved and so we don't know where it goes
and it's important that we stand ready
and willing to assist the pathway to
dialogue it is the European Way if we've
learned to do anything well in Europe
and God knows as many things don't work
so well in Europe today what is
something that does work well it's the
ability to find consensus where before
there was discord and disaster and that
is the core raised on debt of Europe and
it is a philosophy that needs to be
animated in our engagement with today's
Ukraine petcocks special envoy of the
European Parliament to Ukraine thank you
very much for joining us on lotro villa
my pleasure